um I've been giving out uh unreasonable
Hospitality uh by will gadera I'm very
proud that I'm actually also the
publisher of the book and what I met
will I was so blown away by his thinking
he was the owner of 11 Madison Park
which at one point was the best
restaurant in the world and he would
just tell me all the things he was
learning or he had learned about how he
built his restaurant and I realized I
was applying his lessons to my business
and to my life even and so it was so
powerful I I went to him and said you
want to write a book about this stuff
and we worked together on it and I'm
really proud of it it's a great book and
I've given it to a lot of people and
they're finding tremendous value in it
as well everything in there is so
actionable as well so yeah I've been
giving out a lot of copies of
unreasonable Hospitality super proud of
that book